in today's morning rounds a scientific
breakthrough that may eventually allow
many blind people to see a handful of
volunteers are already seeing the
promise of a new device about 18 months
into a five-year clinical study Jonathan
Vigliotti shows us the technology and
how it could transform their lives I
always had a little out hope for Jason
ester Huson was that one day he might
see again the South African lost his
sight in a car accident when he was just
23 years old lost control of the car the
car hit the curb and I just hit the
steering wheel and the the window and
went out the sunroof injuries from the
crash left Jason in a world of total
darkness I think in the first couple of
years of being blind it was just you
have to accept the fact that you're
blind until a friend of his heard about
a clinical trial only for people who
could once see but became blind starting
half a world away at the University of
California Los Angeles
it's a brand new device it's never been
used in humans before dr. nader parot
ian leads the study of an experimental
device called the Orion here's how it
works using a camera attached to a pair
of sunglasses
Orion captures images a person would see
and sends it through a handheld device
to an implant that's been surgically
inserted into the visual part of the
brain the implant then turns those
images into dots of light that the
patient can see they can be various
shapes it could be a circle it could be
an oval it could be a moving line Jason
is one of only six people in the world
who qualified for the study and to
receive the implant the first time that
I saw a little white dot I was
speechless it was the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen you can actually
see the electrode array while not
restoring sight in the traditional sense
what he can see are flashes of light if
I look around I can perceive movement I
can see some light and dark I can tell
you whether a line is vertical hole
Anto or at a 45-degree angle yeah the
device not only allowed Jason to regain
a small part of his vision but some true
independence I cook I clean I can take
out the trash I can sew it laundry but
just the darks are from the lights no
color yet even going for a stroll
outside by himself if I looked down I
can see flashing lights in fact this
study has gone so well in Jason's case
that sometimes even he doesn't realize
how amazing it's been he nonchalantly
was telling me about how he was at the
bar there's a very dark dive bar the
bartender was wearing a white shirt you
can see the bartender walking towards
him and and I just saw two little dots
lighting up and then three and then five
and then she was right in front of me
and she was all shiny and I thought wow
that's cool right you know I said you
know do you realize what you just said a
glimpse into the future that could give
countless people a second chance at
sight for CBS this morning Jonathan
Vigliotti Los Angeles amazing stop it
gives you hope stuff we take for granted
that's really amazing